françois harding se prépare à se joindre
au convoi des camionneurs en compagnie
de quatre autres personnes
l'entrepreneur en construction vide sa
remorque qui servira d'abri ce week-end
pour la manifestation rend à voir les
concerts ont dans leur peau on veut que
ce soit pacifique on veut que le message
passe on veut que les gouvernements
malani arrêtent leur tyrannie non
vaccinés par choix il veut montrer sa
solidarité aux camionneurs et exprimer
son ras-le-bol des mesures sanitaires
mon changement à vos magasins puis que
je me fais de marc d'un code qr je me
sens
vraiment comme emprise en moi la
nouvelle règle qui oblige le camionneur
non vaccinés qui reviennent des états
unis 1,6 au lit pendant 14 jours a mis
en colère ce propriétaire d'une
entreprise de transport le pourquoi que
ça m'amenait à bousiller houle dangereux
de le compte du kyste employés leur
continue à travailler le il va être
privé 1,14 au sens à l'heure chez lui il
ira manifester avec une dizaine de
camionneurs de sa compagnie le
gouvernement est
tout seul si certains se disent
sympathique à leur cause d'autres le
sont moins jean vu sa fortune puis pour
avoir une liberté comme ils veulent
pikine mam qui dribble par le lieu de
nombreux camionneur québécois qui
veulent se joindre au convoi prendront
la route demain matin certains partiront
de la frontière américaine à stanstead
et la colle puis ils convergeront vers
vaudreuil dorion avant de se rendre à
ottawa
ici olivier bastin réseau canada
montréal
en jean poirier camionneurs vous êtes à
tadoussac actuellement bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur roy comment vous vous voyez
depuis deux trois jours ce qui est en
train de se passer au canada
en fait moi c'est sûr que je suis pro
vaccination puis au départ des genres le
convoi au leem la mesure obligatoire de
maxi nation aux frontières c'est déjà
quelque chose que j'adore est pas mais
ce qu'on voit la situation tu voulu les
gens qui se guérit faso on est loin du
du point de départ au long nez cette
greffe toutes sortes puis ça pourrait
être un peu dangereuse pour l'image
d'une parenthèse du monde du camionnage
vous avez depuis le nouveau règlement
avez-vous de traverser la frontière vous
êtes vous vous êtes vacciné comment ça
se passe et la question qu'on pose
beaucoup à ces gens là qui mène fait si
oui mais même si le canada levet
l'obligation vaccinale les américains en
ont une pareille
exactement depuis le 22 les américains
donc ce qu'on attend beaucoup c'est que
c'est différent d'un poste doit il ya
des douaniers américains qu'ils
demandent d'autres n'ont donc se
rattrape fonctions samedi ou dimanche
c'est sûr qu'ils sont pas toujours vue
devait être orientée consignes mais il
suffit d'arriver à un poste puis que ce
douanier leur demande on peut pas entrer
donc même si fédéral abolirait cette
mesure reculerait c'est très surprenant
que minimath on qui reculerait ça avance
absolument viens on va se faire beau
pour représenter paris où ce que se dit
donc comment on peut évaluer il n'y a
pas une sonde h et tous les camionneurs
mais l'appui de ce mouvement a lâché des
camionneurs que vous vous connaissez au
québec par exemple comment on peut
évaluer unsa
l'appui ferme à mon avis représente le
nombre de camionneurs qui font du bio
est sont pas vaccinés parce que nous on
a commencé sur mon employeur nous
demander notre preuve vaccinale à partir
du mois de novembre pas sauvé longtemps
que c'est connu quand on reste
obligations alors donc à peu près juste
et pure et dure aux grisons en auriez ça
change rien à notre vie cette obligation
là on est vacciné de toute façon double
dose une triple dose ça dépend des
individus pas que je voudrais juste en
groupe d'après mon félix environ 10 15%
le decameron doit rectifier ça mais qui
doivent appuyer son museau c'est l'idée
de départ maintenant on est ailleurs ce
qu'on voit là des femmes c'est vraiment
pour défaire les mesures sanitaires
c'est vraiment les activent axé ses
limites des complotistes e round
comme le 6 janvier 2021 en devenir il ya
des gens qui sont pas camionneurs la bac
sont joints et loris tu peut manquer
dont vous êtes on est du quotidien de
neuf camionneurs sur 10 ce qui se passe
actuellement où exactement nous nous
rentrer les pressions on arrive kansas
automatiquement c'est pas un souci le
touriste easy la cdg bande on entend une
fois l'an dans l'application risque ans
pourtant le touriste fait des
va-et-vient noulin commercial une fois
série glee est certain que l'on nous en
parler merci jean poirier un camionneur
vous êtes à tadoussac merci de nous
avons parlé des clercs merci beaucoup au
revoir